[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
heute haben wir mal eine sehr spezielle
Folge denn wir gehen wieder zurück in
der Zeit aber nicht ganz so weit wie wir
es hier schon in mancher Folge getan
haben nur so ein bisschen mehr als 100
Jahre oh ja Mirko die heutige Folge die
es in der Tat etwas speziell keine
klassische Tatort Deutschland Folge in
dem Sinne denn unser heutiger Fall der
hat einige komische Facetten also man
könnte schon fast von Comedy Potential
sprechen und damit herzlich Willkommen
zu Tatort Deutschland mein Name ist
Mirko Kasimir und ich bin Toni Haier sag
mal Toni was ist eigentlich dein
Lieblingswort ich weiß ganz genau worauf
du hinaus willst also jawohl natürlich
und deins ja natürlich auch jawoll oder
sehr wohl zu viel und so weiter und so
weiter na ja
aber jetzt mal ohne Spaß also mein
Lieblingswort das ist
ah schön finde ich gut mein
Lieblingswort ist Marzipan aber das hat
ganz andere Gründe das hat andere Gründe
okay aber ich meine uns Deutschen haftet
ja so ein bisschen das Klischee an dass
wir sehr gehorsam sind und uns an Regeln
halten geradezu überreguliert sind ja
manche sprechen dabei bösartigerweise
von
regelrechtem Kadaver Gehorsam
neben Pünktlichkeit und Effizienz ist
das so eine Sache die wahrscheinlich
jeder auf der Welt unsere klischeehaft
neben Bier und Oktoberfest nachsagt ja
und unsere heutige Geschichte die wird
gern als Beleg dafür genommen denn heute
erzählen wir von Wilhelm Vogt besser
bekannt als der Hauptmann von Köpenick
das ist eine Geschichte die wir alle zu
kennen glauben also da ist ein Typ der
verkleidet sich als Offizier legt damit
ein paar Soldaten rein die im blind
gehorchen und raubt dann das Köpenicker
Rathaus aus aber wenn man etwas genauer
hinschaut dann hat die Geschichte einige
interessante Aspekte und sie erzählt uns
nicht nur etwas über den angeblichen
Untertanen Geist der Deutschen sondern
über uns Menschen allgemein und warum es
Hochstaplern und Betrügern immer wieder
und überall auf der Welt gelingt solche
Dinge durchzuziehen
also Mirko stell uns diesen Herrn doch
mal vor wer war Wilhelm Vogt
der kleine Willi wurde am 13 februar
1849 in Tilsit geboren das ist die Stadt
nach der der Tilsiter Käse benannt ist
Tilsit liegt in der Nähe von Kaliningrad
damals Königsberg zwischen Polen und
Litauen heute ist das eine russische
Enklave der junge Wilhelm jedenfalls ist
genau das Gegenteil von einem gehorsamen
und braven Kind mit 14 muss er wegen
Diebstahls das erste mal für zwei Wochen
ins Gefängnis dabei hat er einen Job von
seinem Vater hat er das Schumacher
Handwerk gelernt seine Wanderjahre als
Geselle führen ihn weit herum er zieht
durch Pommern und Brandenburg aber der
magere Verdienst und die Aussicht auf
ein Leben als Schuhmacher die sagen ihm
nicht so in den folgenden Jahren sammelt
er vier weitere Verurteilungen wegen
Diebstahls und zwei wegen
Urkundenfälschung ein und verbringt
einen guten Teil seiner Zeit im
Gefängnis
1890 versucht er die Kasse eines
Gerichts zu rauben
und Gerichtskasse klauen also da hört
für das Gericht der Spaß auf Wilhelm
Voigt wird zu 15 Jahren Zuchthaus
verurteilt da ist er 41 Jahre alt er
sitzt die ganzen 15 Jahre ab als er
Anfang 1906 entlassen wird ist er 57
Jahre alt aber er hat eine Perspektive
im Gefängnis hat er gute Führung gezeigt
und ein anstaltsgeistlicher hat ihm
einen Job für einen Neuanfang geschafft
Vogt zieht nach Wismar und erhält eine
gesellenstelle beim
hochschuhmachermeister hilbrecht
gehen Sie zurück auf Los mit Ende 50
würde ich jetzt als Monopoly Fan sagen
also ich meine Geselle sein das hatte er
schon mal 40 Jahre vorher und das wohl
ein typischer Fall von Verbrechen das
zahlt sich nicht aus absolut aber
trotzdem hat er Glück viele stehen vor
dem Nichts wenn sie nach so langer Zeit
aus dem Gefängnis entlassen werden
Resozialisierung ist damals noch kein
großes Thema aber für Wilhelm Vogt sieht
es gut aus er muss von Frauen anfangen
aber er kann auch von vorne anfangen ja
das denkt er zumindest und stürzt sich
in die Arbeit der Hochschulmeister ist
mit seinem neuen Gesellen sehr zufrieden
Wilhelm Vogt scheint auf dem besten Weg
auf seine alten Tage doch noch zu einem
ordentlichen Mitglied der Gesellschaft
zu werden und den Behörden auch keinen
Ärger mehr zu machen
tja aber dann machen die Behörden ihm
Ärger aufgrund seiner Vorstrafen erhält
Wilhelm Voigt nach einigen Monaten ein
polizeiliches Aufenthaltsverbot für das
Großherzogtum Mecklenburg dass er sich
im Gefängnis gut betragen hat dass einen
Job hat das spielt alles keine Rolle
heute würde man sicher sagen hier ist
jemand auf einem guten Weg der Mann hat
eine Chance aber 1906 wollen ihm die
Behörden diese Chance einfach nicht
geben also zieht Wilhelm Vogt nach
Rixdorf damals noch eine eigenständige
Gemeinde am Rande Berlins heute ist das
ein Teil von Berlin Neukölln dort wohnt
seine ältere Schwester Berta und ihr
Mann ein Buchbinder er findet eine
Freundin eine 50-jährige Arbeiterin die
im Nachbarhaus wohnt und Wilhelm
versucht alles um sich ein Leben als
braver Staatsbürger aufzubauen er findet
Arbeit in einer Schuhfabrik was
vermutlich noch mal einen Downgrade ist
also vom Gesellen mit der Aussicht auf
einen Gesellen und später vielleicht
Meisterbrief zu einer Art
Fließbandarbeiter aber gut er nimmt was
das Schicksal im anbietet und die
Behörden nehmen es ihm wieder weg im
august 1906 wird ihm auch für Berlin ein
Aufenthaltsverbot erteilt er wird seine
Arbeit verlieren er wird seine
Unterkunft verlieren er wird seine Liebe
verlieren er wird Obdach und arbeitslos
in einer neuen Stadt landen und ahnt
dass man ihn auch dort wegschicken wird
bevor er zeigen kann dass er sein Leben
im Griff hat und die Gesetze achtet ich
sag mal so dass dürfte für so eine
Rückfallquote jetzt nicht sehr
förderlich sein
Jan sauberes glattes ausgewachsen ist
Unrecht ist das und das muss man nur
wissen ihr habt gerade Heinz Rühmann
gehört der den Hauptmann von Köpenick
1956 im gleichnamigen Film verkörpert
hat
wo soll ich den tragen ohne Pass und
ohne Aufenthalt muss doch einen Platz
geben wo der Mensch leben kann mensch
bist du da nur wenn du dich in der
menschliche Ordnung stellst Leben tut
auf einer Wanze richtig die lebend erst
kommt der ganze Friedrich und dann der
Wanzen in Ordnung erster Mensch
Friedrich und dann der Menschen Ordnung
Wilhelm fuckt jedenfalls hat genug von
dieser Menschen Ordnung die ihm keinen
Platz und keine Chance geben will er ist
jetzt ein illegaler nicht aus eigener
Entscheidung sondern auf polizeiliches
Gehalt eine Weile geht dann noch in die
Fabrik dann Ende September erzählt er
seiner Geliebten dass er eine
unerwartete Erbschaft gemacht habe und
trinkt nach odessternisse dann taucht er
unter am 6 Oktober sieht man ihn das
letzte mal in der schuffabrik 10 Tage
braucht Wilhelm um von einem einfachen
Fabrikarbeiter zu einem Hauptmann des
ersten preußischen Garderegiment zu
werden er hat sich bei verschiedenen
Händlern eine entsprechende Uniform
zusammengekauft und er wird den Staat
der im scheinbar keine andere Wahl
lassen will mit seinen eigenen Waffen
schlagen dem Glauben an Autorität Regeln
und Befehle
am 16 oktober 1906 marschiert ein Trupp
gardefiseliere des ersten garderegiments
zu Fuß also heute würde man
Infanteristen sagen auf einer Straße in
der Nähe der damaligen
militärbaderanstalt Plötzensee die
Männer sind auf dem Weg von der
Wachablösung in die Kaserne als sie von
einem Hauptmann ihres Regiments dem
Hauptmann von Malzahn angesprochen
werden
auf dem Weg von der Schwimmschule waren
das war noch mal Heinz Rühmann der
Hauptmann der den kleinen Trupp
angehalten hat ist natürlich kein echter
Hauptmann aber offensichtlich echt genug
der angebliche von Malzahn ist in
Wirklichkeit der verkleidete Wilhelm
Voigt er befragte Soldaten nach ihren
Befehlen und ihrem Ziel und erklärt
Ihnen dann dass sie auf allerhöchsten
Befehl und auf Grundlage einer Kabinetts
oder ab sofort seinem Kommando
unterstellt sein die vier oder fünf
visiliere reichen ihm allerdings nicht
und der Kapern einen zweiten Trupp
Soldaten diesmal vom vierten Garde
Regiment mit 10 oder 11 Mann marschiert
er zum S-Bahnhof pulitzstraße der heißt
heute Westbahnhof von dort geht es mit
dem Zug nach Friedrichshagen die
Soldaten müssen sich gewundert haben
dass sie mit der Bahn zu einem Einsatz
auf allerhöchsten Befehl fahren aber der
Hauptmann erklärt ihnen dass es nicht
möglich gewesen sei Kraftwagen zu
requirieren
von Friedrichshagen geht es zu Fuß acht
Kilometer nach Köpenick damals noch eine
eigenständige Gemeinde vor den Toren
Berlins wenn die Soldaten irgendwelche
Zweifel haben dann sind sie spätestens
bei einer Rast in Rummelsburg Feuer und
Flamme für ihren Hauptmann um noch mal
auf die guten alten Klischees vom Anfang
zurückzukommen was mögen deutsche noch
lieber als Befehle ja richtig ein
Bierchen Hauptmann Vogt gibt eine Runde
aus und genehmigt sich selbst einen
Konjak als sie in Köpenick ankommen
drückt er jedem der Soldaten eine Marke
in die Hand damit sie in der Gaststätte
des Bahnhofs essen können dann erst
erklärte ihnen worin der Befehl von
allerhöchster Stelle besteht
wir werden den Bürgermeister und
vielleicht noch andere Herren verhaften
da haben sie sich aber was vorgenommen
wie lange kann Wilhelm Vogt die Rolle
als Hauptmann von Köpenick durchhalten
was hat er von dem ganzen Theater und
was wurde später aussehen ich würde
sagen Mirko das ist genug Stoff für
einen spannenden zweiten Teil dieser
Folge die hört ihr dann natürlich morgen
fieser
aber wir hoffen ihr seid da natürlich
auch wieder mit dabei eure Toni und euer
Mirko